If you're curious about the long-awaited threequel
to Bad Boys, and some of the drama surrounding
it, look no further.
Here's everything you need to know before
you sit down to watch some massive explosions
and ridiculous action scenes.
It just wouldn't be a Bad Boys film if it
weren't for the bad boys themselves, Will
Smith and Martin Lawrence.
Obviously, both Smith and Lawrence are returning
in their franchise roles as detectives Mike
Lowrey and Marcus Burnett, and they'll still
use extreme measures to combat some of the
worst crime in Miami.
If you need a refresher, Will Smith's character,
Mike Lowrey, is the rich ladies man of the
team, while Lawrence's Marcus Burnett is more
the exasperated family man.
Together, they're the bad boys of the Miami
Police Department.
There's one other crucial aspect to the Bad
Boys franchise, and that's the irritated,
and grudgingly respectful, Captain Howard.
Luckily, Joe Pantoliano will also be returning
in Bad Boys for Life.
We're guessing that time hasn't changed how
fed up he is with our favorite detectives,
even if he always ends up having their backs
anyway.
I got three cops critical, kids dying on the
street from souped-up X. I do not want these
animals taking over my city!"
We know a bit of the story going into Bad
Boys for Life, thanks to some official production
notes and the trailers released so far.
The story focuses on AMMO, an elite squad
within the Miami Police Department.
Their current target is Armando Armas, a violent
young cartel leader.
Armas has his crosshairs focused on Detective
Lowrey, and he has a prior history with our
heroes.
With Armas on the hunt, Lowrey and Burnett
are pulled back into the fray, despite the
fact that Burnett seems to have his eye on
retirement.
They start working with AMMO's leader to stop
the threat that Armas poses.
Naturally, AMMO's leader is also a former
flame of Detective Lowrey's, and he considers
her the one that got away.
Most of the actors showing up in Bad Boys
for Life are new to the franchise, but there's
a pretty good mix of up-and-coming actors
and well-established ones.
The big one joining the cast is Jacob Scipio,
who will portray Armando Armas, the film's
villain.
His character is described as having a "vicious,
taunting nature" and he has a past connection
with our detectives.
Paola Nunez, a star of Mexican television
and film, is also joining Bad Boys for Life
as Mike's ex, a criminal psychologist and
the aforementioned head of AMMO.
We also know a few actors who will play roles
as members of this elite squad: Vanessa Hudgens,
Alexander Ludwig, and Charles Melton will
all be part of the team.
It's a Bad Boys film, so it probably isn't
much of a stretch to guess that at least one
of them is a secret bad guy.
Finally, one interesting wrinkle in the plot
description is that Armas targets our heroes
under the direction of his mother.
We don't know for sure who plays this character,
but Kate del Castillo, who has been cast in
an undisclosed role, seems like a good bet.
It seems like all the elements for a Bad Boys
film are here, but Bad Boys for Life is missing
one significant piece: Michael Bay.
Instead, the directing duo of Adil El Arbi
and Bilall Fallah are at the helm.
They previously directed Black, Gangsta, and
have also signed to direct Beverly Hills Cop
4.
They may not have been the first choices to
take on Bad Boys for Life, but they were the
ones who managed to get the troubled production
to the finish line.
Why did it take so long for a third Bad Boys
movie to explode onto the screen?
Well, the project had to sail some troubled
waters.
Will Smith has reportedly had a sequel in
mind since at least 2008, but multiple delays
had many people thinking it may never happen
at all.
The original director was going to be Joe
Carnahan, who's helmed big action movies like
Smokin' Aces and The A-Team.
However, Carnahan apparently clashed with
Will Smith about the creative direction of
Bad Boys for Life, and was subsequently let
go from the project.
It's unclear exactly what caused the rift,
but Carnahan is still credited as co-writer
on the film's screenplay.
Considering all the talk in the trailer of
this being "the last ride" for our detective
heroes, it seems likely that Bad Boys for
Life is the end of their story.
However, if they decide to ever truly reboot
the Bad Boys franchise, one Hollywood actor
has already thrown his name in the ring to
take up the reins.
Winston Duke, who played M'Baku in Black Panther
and starred in Jordan Peele's Us, told the
The Deadline Podcast that he would love to
star if they ever rebooted Bad Boys.
He also offered Black Panther co-star, Daniel
Kaluuya, as the person he would choose to
partner up with if it ever did get off the
ground.
Considering the timing, it seems unlikely
that a Bad Boys reboot will happen any time
soon, but the prospect of Duke and Kaluuya
teaming up is a great idea nonetheless.
With all the years that have passed since
Bad Boys II, you're probably eager to see
some things blow up already.
The trailers released so far have pretty much
everything you could want.
Lowery exasperated at Burnett's antics?
Check.
"I got this.
I'm gonna penetrate this man's soul with my
heart."
"What?"
Captain Howard swearing a whole bunch?
Check.
A bunch of people singing "Bad Boys" by Inner
Circle?
Oh, yes.
And, of course, the explosions.
So many explosions.
You'll be able to see them all when the film
blasts into theaters on January 17th, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
upcoming movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.